president Trump will begin his fourth of
July weekend with a visit to Mount
Rushmore tonight more than 7,000 people
are expected to attend the celebration
they're encouraged but not required to
wear masks the president praised the
country's response to the corona virus
yesterday after hearing some good news
on the economy Paula Reid reports from
the White House on that President Trump
is banking on an economic recovery to
propel him to reelection and on Thursday
he touted the June unemployment numbers
today's announcement proves that our
economy is roaring back it's coming back
extremely strong but some economic
analysts say the better than expected
numbers may be deceiving as they only
reflect reopening in early June and do
not account for recent shutdowns in the
wake of a new surge of cases we have
some areas where we're putting out the
flames or the fires and that's working
out well thank you very much the
president left the briefing without
taking questions from reporters but did
later acknowledge the record number of
new cases this week this is coming back
and we haven't totally succeeded yet we
will soon but we haven't killed all of
the virus yet former Vice President Joe
Biden accused his 2020 rival of bungling
the response to the pandemic quick
claiming victory with almost 15 million
Americans still out of work because of
the crisis on Thursday one of the
president's allies former presidential
candidate Herman Cain revealed that he
had tested positive for the virus on
June 29th his statement did not say
where he contracted the virus but just
nine days earlier he had tweeted a photo
of himself at the president's rally in
Tulsa without a mask the administration
continues to rely on a states-led
approach for things like mask
requirements dr. Anthony Fauci says as
individual states reopen the u.s. is
seeing a record number of new cases that
is not good news we've got to get that
under control or we risk an even greater
outbreak in the United States here in
Washington the mayor is discouraging
people from hosting large gatherings
over the holiday weekend but she does
not control what happens on federal
property and tomorrow the president will
host a salute to America which will
include music fireworks even flyovers
but the city's mayor says she has
communicated to the administration that
she does not believe that this event
complies with the administration's own
best practices on preventing the spread
of coronavirus Tony a lot of tension
there between local and federal Paula
thank you very much